[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ravis de vous
retrouver après une semaine d'absence
pour cause de cas contactez mission à
nouveau masque et ce soit pour des
raisons sanitaires évidente et pis pour
l'exemple alors de quoi parle-t-on ce
soit d'une proposition de loi de la
majorité qui fait polémique elle prévoit
de protéger ce qui nous protège les
policiers avec toute une série de
mesures mais elle prévoit aussi
l'interdiction à certaines conditions de
diffuser sur les réseaux sociaux
les policiers leur visage lors
d'opérations la défenseure des droits
met en garde contre une atteinte
fondamentale à la liberté d'informer on
en parle dans un instant avec nos
invités et on en parlera
particulièrement avec notre grand témoin
ce soir c'est lui qui porte ce texte
c'est l'un des commissaires de police
les plus célèbres de france charlie
hebdo lippert cacher le bataclan il
tenait les commandes du raid
durant l'année noire de 2015 il revient
avec un livre dans lequel il témoigne de
son expérience avec l'ancien patron du
gign
jean-michel fauvergue est avec nous ce
soir enfin on parlera aussi des
conséquences économiques dures
confinement elles sont budgétés rassure
le gouvernement bruno le maire dégaine
toute une série de nouvelles mesures de
soutien mais beaucoup d'entreprises
n'auront pas les reins assez solides
pour survivre à cette deuxième vague et
c'est le scénario d'un noël confiné qui
se dessine
décryptage dans la dernière partie de
cette émission voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti hashtag sévère
pour réagir tout de suite
classé débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir jean michel fauvergue
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ravis de vous accueillir du raid
à l'assemblée on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur ce parcours singulier vous
êtes député en marche de cinéma vous
publiez avec thierry orosco l'ancien
patron du gign gign raid deux patrons
face aux nouvelles menaces
on en parlera tout à l'heure ses schémas
roeg édition mais on va d'abord je le
disais dans le sommaire débattre de
votre proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale n arrive dans l'hémicycle la
semaine prochaine en début de semaine et
elle a été discuté toute la semaine
dernière en commission elle fait déjà
couler beaucoup d'encre n'est ce pas
stéphane peu bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes député communiste de
seine saint denis vous avez épluché ce
texte en commission la semaine dernière
david dufresne est avec nous également
via skype est ce qu'il est là david
dufresne
il est là bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes journaliste réalisateur
l'auteur de nombreux films et de
nombreux ouvrages sur les violences
policières vous avez lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux une pétition contre
l'article 24 de ce texte de quoi
s'agit-il
on va en parler dans un tout petit
instant enfin j'accueille avec plaisir
derrière son écran françois bersani
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
secrétaire départemental unité sgp
police fo dont les yvelines et vous nous
direz ce que vous pensez et bien de cet
article 24 tout de suite de quoi
s'agit-il stéphane bonsoir on sort rien
bonsoir à tous stéphane blakowski qui va
ouvrir le bal avec s'oublier d'actu pour
démarrer ce débat si j'ai bien compris
tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir explication
de textes autour d'un article qui fait
polémique
alors si j'ai bien compris myriam si
vous filmez une intervention de police
pour ensuite diffuser les images soit à
la télé soit sur des réseaux sociaux est
donc bientôt ça pourrait vous valoir
jusqu'à un an de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé alors sorte cas c'est ce que
prévoit l'article 24 dont on va parler
ce soir là qui est le 24ème article la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale
attention pour risquer une peine aussi
sévère
il faudra que les vidéos qui sont
diffusées le soient faites dans
l'intention de nuire à l'intégrité
physique ou psychique des policiers
alors ça veut dire quoi précisément
l'intégrité physique ou psychique des
policiers bah justement c'est un point
de la loi qui n'est pas forcément très
très clair en tout cas c'est ce
qu'estime le défenseur des droits qui a
donné un avis sur la proposition de loi
et qui estiment que les termes employés
dans l'article 24 sont trop imprécis et
que du coup ça pourrait lui nuire au
final à la liberté d'expression donc
cette inquiétude est évidemment partagé
par les journalistes quasiment toutes
les rédactions ont publié aujourd'hui
une tribune dans le monde pour demander
carrément le retrait de cet article 24
et bien sûr ce qui inquiète les
journalistes c'est qu'on leur interdise
de diffuser par exemple des vidéos de
violences policières au prétexte d'une
supposée intention de nuire aux
policiers alors est-ce qu'elle va
restreindre la liberté de la presse
cette loi cet article 24 officiellement
non non ce n'est pas fait pour ça
d'ailleurs christophe castaner conquis
et le président du groupe en marche qui
était l'ancien musée l'intérieur il
était ce matin sur france inter puis il
essayait de préciser un peu les choses
pour bien prêt pour bien expliquer ce
que prévoit cet article et selon lui la
liberté de la passe d absolument pas
menacé en écoute tous les médias libres
et tous les français qui voudraient
filmer les forces de sécurité intérieure
en interventions seront libres de le
filmer seront libres de diffuser cela
sauf s'il ya volonté de nuire à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique avec
des menaces de mort par exemple et ce
sera pas apprécié par la police
ce sera apprécié par un magistrat
position de christophe castaner puis
avait alice taureau qui était la
rapporteuse de la proposition de loi me
défends
notre avis mais qui s est exprimée
devant la commission des lois puis elle
a pu donner des exemples quand on dit
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une intention
malveillante et ben elle donne des
exemples en écoute je vais vous donner
un exemple ce sont des forces de l'ordre
qui peuvent être reconnus des agents qui
sont reconnues qui sont identifiables et
qui sont jetés en pâture sur les réseaux
sociaux avec des appels à la violence
des appels aux représailles et qui
peuvent engendrer des conséquences très
graves ça n'est pas un cas d'école ça
veut dire que le but du texte n'est pas
d'interdire aux journalistes de filmer
policier alors pas du tout myriam un
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'intérieur
lui-même qui était devant un congrès de
syndicats policiers début septembre a
dit ben on n'empêchera jamais les gens
me filmer mais le problème c'est que le
même jour gérald darmanin a aussi promis
il a fait une promesse aux politiques
étaient là qui serait bientôt
obligatoire de flouter les visages des
policiers ou des gendarmes dans
l'édifice dans les vidéos qu'on diffuse
la télé ou sur les réseaux sociaux lors
et les articles qui était paru à la
presse pour montrer sa et donc voyez que
c'était son intention
et pourtant je sais pas il parce qu'elle
prévoit le texte il n'est pas question
d'interdire de flouter le visage des
policiers c'est ça alors pas du tout non
c'est pas du tout ce qui est prévu dans
la proposition de loi mais il ya encore
un problème et le problème c'est sur
l'homme c'est ce que dit gérald darmanin
puisque il n'hésite pas lui maintenant à
prétendre le contraire
il va même jusqu'à aller plus loin que
l'obligation de flouter il était chez
bourdin la semaine dernière il a
clairement dit que sa promesse serait
tenu et que la loi interdirait bientôt
de diffuser carrément des images des
policiers on écoute ses propos j'avais
fait une promesse qui était de ne plus
pouvoir diffuser les images des
policiers des gendarmes sur les réseaux
sociaux
cette promesse sera tenue puisque la loi
prévoira l'interdiction de la diffusion
il saisit la loi alors forcément on a un
peu l'impression qu'il ya deux versions
la qui ce qui se concurrencent alors
quelle est la bonne version celle de
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur ou
celle du nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
alors si on s'en réfère aux textes celle
de la proposition de loi pour l'instant
c'est quand même christophe castaner qui
est dans le vrai donc plutôt que
darmanin mais simplement dans
l'impression que le miz darmanin lui
essaie de jouer les monsieur plus que il
cherche à faire plaisir aux aux forces
de l'ordre qui surtout qu'il est un peu
engagés par la promesse qu'il a fait
donc comme comme disait la grand mère de
martine aubry quand c'est flou c'est
qu'il ya un loup dont
tatin l'eau autour de sa maison je pose
la question jean michel fauvergue alors
qu'il a raison mais c'est darmanin
castetner ou darmanin n'y comprend alors
remplir chose
jean-michel euphorique j'ai couvert
c'est un seul mot soit castanheira
darmana où je vais vous éclairer j'ai
vous éclairer puisque vous poser des
questions en clair vous êtes en train de
me demander mon avis sur une proposition
de loi une proposition de loi c les
députés 1 qui la font à la marche
rédigé par les députés savoir qui c'est
qui à raison de deux ministres qui
appartiennent à l'exécutif ou commun
dans mon appartement appartenait les
ch'tis alors ceux qui ont raison ce dans
un seul à ce sont les députés parce que
c'est eux qui ont écrit ça donc vous
êtes en train de m'interroger sur mon
texte pas sur notre texte
donc notre texte dit que je vais vous le
dire parce que c'est important ce qui ce
qui sera puni d'un an d'emprisonnement
45000 euros d'amendé
c'est le fait de diffuser diffusé pas de
film et par quelque moyen que ce soit et
quel qu'en soit le support
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
l'intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image d'un visage ou tout autre
élément d'identification sauf le riu que
je comprends assez que d'arman alors il
y aura pas d'obligation fonctionner la
loi ne prévoit ni d'obligation de la
paix ni d'obligations et d'interdictions
d'ici peu un arbitre de rugby et c'est
pas moi de gérer darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur ne tiendra pas sa promesse
avec votre texte bien sûr que non la
promesse qui a été faite et par non
seulement ont d'ailleurs par le ministre
l'intérieur mais aussi au niveau le plus
haut de l'état c'est de protéger ce qui
nous protège et ce texte tient cette
promesse la protéger ce qui nous protège
pourquoi les protéger
tout ça on s'étouffe avec ses masques à
ses terres et c'est pourquoi les
produits
pourquoi les protéger les protéger parce
que leur rôle a eu c'est de nous
protéger nous et parce qu'ils sont
quelquefois donné en pâture par un
certain nombre de personnes pas les
journalistes un certain nombre de
personnes qui vont les films et qui vont
donner leur adresse qui ont donné leurs
réseaux leurs de leurs épouses qui vont
donner l'adresse
où ils emmènent leurs enfants à quai les
colis sont etc jeudi il a dit c'est chic
ou physx et c'est le magistrat
soyons très clairs
moi je connais quelques maintenant je
connais pas mal de pas mal de
journalistes je n'ai jamais connu jamais
connu un seul journaliste professionnel
un seul journaliste qui se sert des
images qui n'est qu'il qu'il filme pour
donner l'adresse des policiers pour dire
de ce policier habitent ici aller le
chercher
jamais j'ai connu de profession nous
diront ça par contre par contre on a
connu et on a des exemples là dessus des
gens qui disent mal intentionnés qui
dans leurs rapports avec la police alors
filmé les politiques bien compris il
faut qu'il ya une intention malveillante
vous défendez cette mesure 7 24 vous
n'avez pas l'impression qu' il existe
déjà des infractions des délits pour
menaces de mort pour incitation à la
haine provocation à la violence qu'ils
sont suffisant il faut aller plus loin
avec cet article 1 4 si on a si on a
écrit cet article là c'est que le droit
existant n'était pas suffisant c'est
dans ce cadre là et si on a écrit écrit
cet article là c'est parce qu'on a des
exemples de terrain qui nous remontent
quasiment tous les récits zélés
précisément concrètement en disant non
mais vous avez plusieurs exemples je
viens de vous le dire quand on donne le
06 06 de la femme d'un vin d'un
fonctionnaire de police ou d'un gendarme
quand on quand on dit l'endroit où ses
enfants sont 14es la boule au ventre la
boule au ventre des policiers de voir
leurs proches menacée qu'est ce que vous
répondez de stéphane peut il est
nécessaire cet article ou pas d'abord vu
qu' il faut protéger
les policiers ils doivent pas être mis à
la vindicte
sur le plan personnel sur le plan
familial c'est bien évident moi je pense
qu'il ya tout ce qui est tout ce qu'il
faut dans dans la loi commune et déjà
existantes pour pouvoir y faire face et
on peut pas ne pas entendre la
l'inquiétude de la presse notamment
surtout avec ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années moi je fais partie d'un
député qu'un café sont son apprentissage
de parlementaire avec la commission
denquête benalla mais qui peut dire que
les images qui ont été diffusées après
elle se fera les regarder est-ce que
c'était une attaque à l'intégrité
psychologique de monsieur benalla on
peut le penser
il a dû vivre les semaines qui ont suivi
la diffusion de ces images là bas c'est
difficilement et quand on sait que
comment ça c'est fini pour lui
bon on pouvait comprendre qu'ils sont
inquiets de fallait-il les diffuser ou
pas heureusement car j'ai trouvé
regarder puisque vous vous nous en
parler vous souvenez c'était le 1er mai
2018 et celle des grands sion
interpellation musclée d'alexion de
benhaddad
supporters brassard police à l'époque
considérait lui jeté des objets sur
s'était pas manifestants simplement très
clair qu'on soit très claire jeune est
mort je vais aller voir david dufresne
david dufresne 7 cette image là
d'alexandre benalla avec ce texte vous
craignez qu'elles ne soient plus
diffusées
david dufresne oui vous bon soir écoutez
on a bien compris au début de votre
émission là là
l'immense confusion qui règne chez des
ministres et des anciens ministres
oui on peut dire que cette image ne
serait pas diffusée telle qu'elle l'a
été et donc on n'aurait pas connu cette
affaire des tapas rage est super ce sont
des centaines et de ce son on vous dit
tout sur des sondages comme secte sikh
serait pas qu'ils ne seraient plus
diffusés à blanc réalité parce que on
comprend bien que dans l'idée de
d'atteinte psychique d'atteinte physique
etc
on est dans quelque chose d'extrêmement
flou et moi j'en veux pas à monsieur
fauvergue cet article là c'est pas le
sien madame madame madame toro elle même
qui est co-rapporteur avec vous a lâché
le morceau il ya quelques heures à bfm
en expliquant que c'était le président
de la république qui avait fait cette
promesse aux syndicats de police donc
c'est pour l'intérêt des syndicats de
police que vous faites ça pas du tout
pour l'intérêt du public et je crois que
ils font revenir vraiment à la base la
base c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme
c'est l'article 12 de des droits de
l'homme qui nous dit simplement il faut
le rappeler
tel qu'il est la garantie des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nécessite une
force publique forces publiques ça veut
dire qu'on doit pouvoir la regarder
qu'on doit pouvoir la voir que c'est au
nom de tous et pâques tous qu'elle
s'exerce pas de manière anonyme
aujourd'hui on voit de plus en plus de
policiers qui sont cagoulés je parle pas
de vos hommes de vos anciens hommes du
raid qui le sont légalement je parle de
tous les autres de ceux qui font de la
sécurité publique qui font du maintien
d'ordre qui sont cagoule
je parle de ces policiers qui masquent
leur plein
minéralogiques jeu je parle de ces
journalistes qui ont été au moins à peu
près environ 200 pendant les gilets
jaunes qui ont été entravés c'est à dire
des objectifs visés des des téléphones
matraques et des effacements de cartes
mémoires des exigences de carte de
presse de choses qui sont autant d'
entrave à la liberté de la presse donc
si vous voulez cette rare cet article 24
de votre proposition de loi en fait ils
manient deux choses émaner d'une part
une véritable assaut un véritable assaut
sur la liberté d'informer mais aussi la
liberté de chaque citoyen de films et de
documentaires alors après vous nous
dites elles évidemment 77,91 cet
argument et entendable évidemment
protéger les forces nord qui sont
menacés mais partent des mois dans la
loi de 1881 que vous voulez modifier
c'est écrit dans la diffamation il ya la
volonté de nuit il ya la nuisance vous
pouvez attaquer quelqu'un parce qu'il a
une volonté de nuire
vous pouvez attaquer quelqu'un parce que
il veut il
vos menaces vous pouvez attaquer
quelqu'un parce qu'ils étaient la
provocation à la commission d'un crime
ou d'un délit tout ça existe on ne voit
absolument pas le rapport avec le
floutage très bien on le fait on le fait
maintenant dix jours jours donnerait la
parole david dufresne mais j'aimerais
qu'on écoute monsieur barzani qui va qui
va vous répondre parce que il est sur le
terrain
bon score qu'est ce que vous répondez à
david dufresne en fait les journalistes
par peur de poursuites judiciaires vont
peut-être s'autocensurer il ya une
véritable atteinte à la liberté
d'informer mais au delà une atteinte
démocratique avec cet article 24
alors merci myriam de nous donner la
parole à travers moi les policiers de ce
pays parce que bon on répondra de celui
friend ce qui freine il a une idéologie
qui est très bien connu il mène un
combat alors personnel contre les forces
de l'ordre depuis plusieurs années et
son sens de commerce il le fait des
films antipolis
il encourage les militants le gilet
jaune
si vous allez on essaye de bateaux se
parler en même temps je voudrais que
vous répondez à cette question simple il
existe est il venu voir le film film
dans son syndicat a exigé le retrait
d'une subvention est ce que monsieur est
venu le voir arrêter de arrêter de jeter
l'anathème dès que dès que des gens
veulent exercer simplement un esprit
critique
je ne suis dans aucune eau n je suis
critique j'ai le droit de l'être
non monsieur par année répondez à
monsieur david dufresne
il existe déjà des dispositifs dans le
code pénal qui protège les policiers
alors ccpo c'est aussi ce que disait
monsieur peut tout à l'heure comme quoi
ils l'arsenal législatif existait déjà
pour éviter que le visage des policiers
ou des policiers soient affichés sur les
réseaux sociaux et faux ça n'existe pas
et par exemple l'infraction de sites est
monsieur peu la menace de mort la menace
de mort ne tient pas
lorsqu'on affiche des photos des images
de policiers sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut savoir quand même d'où ça vient
cette idée là et cette revendication la
des forces de police ça vient pas de
bière on avait déjà notre organisation
avec monsieur brand le sénateur grand
demandé il ya plusieurs mois plusieurs
années à ce que les policiers spa foot
et pourquoi parce que depuis l'attentât
de magnanville il faut pas il faut quand
même pas passer non plus l'eponge sur ce
fait là en 2016 il ya une magnanville
des policiers qui avaient été suivies
par un terroriste mais qui avaient été
assassinés à leur domicile et depuis
magnanville on a vu surgir sur les
réseaux sociaux des sites souvent des
sites estampillés akkad donc je vous
rappelle à tous les flics sont des
bâtards des kouriles j'en passe et des
meilleurs où certains certains
soi-disant journalistes ou soi-disant
défenseurs des droits affichait donc des
polices n'estimez et essayer de donner
leur identification leur domicile
lalanne de voiture et cette réponse
merci au droit de réponse est obligé de
faire un peu les arbitres parce que
c'est compliqué quand on est à distance
au fond vous réclamez le floutage mais
c'est pas ce qui est dans le texte
monsieur barça dit jean-michel fauvergue
eric ciotti a déposé une proposition de
loi qui demandait à ce qu'au fond puisse
diffuser les images des policiers en
opération mais qu'ils soient floutées
pourquoi vous n'avez pas retenu cela
vous au fond ce que vous dites c'est qui
pire sous certaines conditions la
malveillance on a diffusion des images
je pense que je voudrais ce que je
voudrais quand même relevé avant de
répondre à des choses que je n'ai pas
fait ce que je voudrais c'est ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que y'a quand
même je ne comprends pas les arguments
qui me sont qui me sont déployés
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de dire
tous les uns et les autres que ça existe
déjà
ça existe déjà dans le code pénal délit
par il ne faut pas et qu'il ne faut pas
légiférer or si ça existe déjà
pourquoi on a ce procès d'intention
puisque ça devrait déjà existé aussi
cette atteinte
un supporter un insupportable à la
liberté de la presse existe déjà
je comprends pas trop là-dessus
maintenant nous n'avons pas demandé de
droit de floutage parce que c'est pas ça
que nous visons je vais vous redire
encore une encore une fois nous voulons
que les que les voulait dissuader au
voulons que les que les journalises la
diffusion à faire leur job sans aucun
problème et ils le feront
et ils le feront leur lot important
parce que c'est évidemment si on était
très compliqué parce que c'est très
important et que je voudrais qu'on parle
aussi de la question des policiers
municipaux
vous vous souvenez le 3 janvier 2020 un
livreur cédric chou via a fait l'objet
d'une interpellation à paris avec un
plaquage contrat l'on va revoir les
images
il ya eu une clé d'étranglement il meurt
à l'hôpital dans les heures qui suivent
vous avez forcément lui la réaction de
sa fille sa fille explique que si la
proposition de loi est votée on n'aurait
pas pu passer six pompes et on n'aurait
pas pu obtenir justice et faux est ce
que vous les réponses reçues faut tout
est faux vous êtes en train de me sortir
le cas bénins là le cash souviens très
bien tant mieux qui est d'autant mieux
qu'ils la presse et qu'il la presse
qu'il est citoyen qui lance alerte
tant mieux qu'ils essaient des citoyens
décimés ces citoyens là ils n'ont pas
voulu quand ils ont filmé benalla quand
ils ont filmé chou via ou d'autres ils
n'ont pas voulu faire en sorte de porter
des atteintes un
importante physique ou psychique aux
policiers ils en voulaient pas contre
les policiers physiquement ils en
voulaient contre l'action des policiers
qu'ils estimaient illégale et ça demain
ça sera la même chose donc vous les
exemples que vous me dites sont pas bons
les immatures continuer à être enfin si
vous voulez bon jeu
[Musique]
je comprends je comprends l'inquiétude
des policiers comme je comprends aussi
l'inquiétude des élus jeu
malheureusement je viens aujourd'hui
d'avoir dans mon département un maire
qui se fait saccagé sa maison avec des
croix gammées bon partir du moment où on
est dans un pays où tout peut se dire et
n'importe quoi dans la plus grande des
impunités tout le monde tous ceux qui
exercent quelques responsabilités que ce
soit du policier à l'enseignant ou à
l'élue est exposé il faut absolument
légiférer et mettre un terme à cela et à
ce déferlement de haine mais ma
préoccupation s'agissant de cette
proposition de loi
moi je constate je suis pas le seul tout
le monde il y à une distance qui se crée
entre la population et sa police
je parle pas entre les délinquants et la
police parce que ça c'est normal que les
relations soient mauvaises linverse très
inquiétant mais mais mais je parle de la
population la population au net les
honnêtes gens qui ont vide qui parfois
ont une relation plus compliqué avec la
police et d'articles alors il m'a je
pense qu'il faut à tout prix créer des
conditions dans le travail des policiers
dans la relation avec la population dans
le rétablissement d'une police de
proximité qu'il faut rétablir des
relations de confiance entre la
population et la police
il n'y a pas de police républicaine qui
ne soit pas vain quand même nous sommes
dans un pays où la police est pas la
police de l'état
c'est la police du peuple de la police
de la république c'est la police donc si
le peuple n'a pas confiance ou est trop
défiant visage et les
citoyen je voudrais qu'on avance parce
que je ne pense pas que nous allons vous
réconcilier sur cet article 24 juin on
verra d'ailleurs on verra d'ailleurs sur
le fond j'entends s'il est
constitutionnel ou pas des questions
juridiques se pose
l'autre grand volet du texte et vous
restez avec nous monsieur barça ni
monsieur dufresne
il concerne la police municipale le
texte prévoit de renforcer ses moyens et
ses prérogatives les policiers
municipaux sont évidemment notablement
développer en france on l'a vu récemment
d'ailleurs lors de leurs interventions
crucial lors d'attentats terroristes
nous sommes allés dans votre
circonscription jean michel fauvergue
suivre une patrouille à roissy en brie
en seine et marne
reportage clément perreault en
patrouille dans un quartier résidentiel
ces policiers municipaux assurent une
mission classique de surveillance n'aura
descendre du véhicule et on va les voir
faire dans le contexte de menaces
terroristes il vérifie les alentours de
la synagogue leur tenue et leurs
équipements sont pratiquement identiques
à ceux de la police nationale armes à
feu incluse on a matraque télescopique
mon la radio ferveur supplémentaires
d'armes de poing ce qui change c'est le
domaine de compétence plus restreint
pour l'instant on peut faire une prise
de contact avec lui maintenant on pourra
pas le comprenez son identité il n'y a
pas d'infraction ne peut pas faire grand
chose à part appelé les collègues de la
police n'a la police nationale et leur
expliquer qu'un individu qui rôdent
contrôles d'identité impossible pas
d'accès direct aux fichiers
d'immatriculation des limites que ces
policiers souvent en première ligne ont
du mal à comprendre là des groupes
d'individus qui n'hésite pas maintenant
à attirer des feux d'artifice ont autres
sur les fonctionnaires de police un
sérieux aussi pour décoller quand police
municipale donc voilà il ne faut
maintenant une législation qui nous
permettent d'intervenir le mieux
possible
[Musique]
ici pourtant la police municipale
s'impose clairement comme la première
référence en matière de sécurité
roissy-en-brie n'a pas de commissariats
dans ce commerce
les policiers municipaux viennent
vérifier la bonne application des
mesures cinq ou six devoir vous avez un
problème dans votre magasin c'est ce que
vous appelez oui parce que l'on à leur
numéro personnel c'est le plus réactif
c'est les plus proches et puis surtout
qu'on les connaît fait pas de 17
vous faites le portable de la personne
que vous connaissez j'aurai plus
tendance à les appeler directement
directement eux puisque je les vois très
régulièrement comme beaucoup de communes
françaises roissy en brie a massivement
investi dans sa police municipale depuis
son élection en 2015 le maire à tripler
les effectifs et équiper la ville de 50
caméras de vidéosurveillance y avait un
besoin criant de rassurer nos
populations de moins en moins
d'effectifs de police nationale sur
notre territoire de roissy en brie et
aussi d'ailleurs je penserai sur le
territoire francilien et en france en
général donc un besoin d'une expression
des mers entre de mettre du bleu dans
nos rues pour rassurer nos habitants et
ça permet aussi de remonter et les
informent les informations auprès des
autorités nationales à roissy-en-brie la
police municipale représente aujourd'hui
8 % du budget global de la mairie
jean-michel fauvergue les policiers
municipaux qu'à interroger clément
perreault réclame deux choses la
possibilité de faire des contrôles
d'identité et la possibilité d'accéder
aux fichiers d'immatriculation des
voitures texte at il leur donnait ses
droits sur la possibilité de faire des
contrôles d'identité clairement non non
il n'est pas prévu de 2,9 gradés ces
policiers de leur donner les
qualifications nécessaires pour qu'ils
accèdent aux contrôles d'identité
pourquoi parce que dans l'état actuel
des choses ils n'en n'ont pas besoin
parce que et je le dis tout à fait
clairement gemmois titre personnel j'ai
toujours considéré que le contrôle
d'identité n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
du travail de police qu'on soit clair là
dessus mais parce que leur ampleur leur
job le boulot des polices municipales
c'est ce que disait stéphane peut tout à
l'heure c'est d'être au contact de la
population d'avoir le contact avec cette
population est de garder ce contact sur
la population
si en augmenter leur qualification
judiciaire il serait pris par des
affaires judiciaires et des procédures
et ils ne seraient plus sur le terrain
comme ils doivent aller donc c'est un
but de cette loi si on se rend bien
compte que sur le terrain ce sont eux
souvent qu il
face aux pires menaces mais on l'a vu
récemment qui fera conflans sainte
honorine notamment mais bien évidemment
qu'ils fassent face au au pire menace
est quelque chose de d'acter mais c'est
pas avec des contrôles d'identité
avaient fait face aux menaces physiques
en face de vous c'est avec d'autres
d'autres systèmes et les pouvoirs qu'on
leur donne
là ce sont des pouvoirs importants
rapidement décrivez lady sur ces cds
pouvoir de 2,2
d'amande forfaitaire qui leur sont
données qui leur permet de mettre demain
de travailler sur cette délinquance et
sur cette incivilité que les gens
réclament dans une ville que les
concitoyens réclame c'est à dire ceux
qui vont vous embêter ceux qui font du
rodéo ceux qui font des tags ceux qui
déposent des ordures etc etc tu as plus
plus comme ils sont autorisés comme tout
citoyen l'intervention et on l'a vu
dernièrement s'il se passait quelque
chose de plus grave et deux plus
importants par exemple à nice plus cette
intervention là mais qui constat
évidemment occasionnels constaté un
délit pour pouvoir contrôler l'identité
de quelqu'un pour pouvoir le punir on a
vendu demander des papiers puisqu'on
doit remplir un papier pour une amende
on doit constater un délit c'est ça que
vous dites non c'est pas du tout ce que
j'ai dit non a commenté pour mettre une
amende forfaitaire si on n'a pas
identifiés at elle un relevé d'identité
c'est pas un contrôle d'identité citant
relevé latinos et lanners et les fêtes
par le code pénal
on voit que l'on voit de plus en plus de
mères décide d'armes et leur police
municipale c'est le cas à nice
évidemment il y a dans ce texte nouvelle
un nouveau dispositif pour paris ça va
changer beaucoup de choses la police
municipale qui l'a ne sera pas armé vous
accompagner ce mouvement de la majorité
là-dessus oblige de trois plus après moi
je trouve que dans la proposition de loi
le
autant j'ai désaccord sur un certain
nombre de choses je pense que la
proposition de loi comme mérite
d'essayer de préciser un peu qui fait
quoi dans la sécurité globale parce
qu'il ya la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
il ya des polices municipales il ya
aussi beaucoup de sociétés de sécurité
privées et c'est bien de dire à un
moment donné qui fait quoi
quelles sont les limites et les
périmètres de chacun donc sur ce sujet
là moi je
je n'ai pas si je vais faire non et puis
je ferai des propositions pour essayer
d'améliorer la précision de ses missions
mais j'ai rapidement parce que
j'aimerais qu'on a fait intervenir non
mais je cale du stand réaction à ce que
disait le maire de roissy-en-brie il a
dit quand même deux choses qui
finalement ma m'interpelle et doivent
nous tous nous interpeller il dit
pourquoi j'ai autant de policiers
municipaux c'est parce que j'ai constaté
une disparition progressive ou une
baisse progressive de la police
nationale et deuxièmement on dit ça fait
8 % du budget de roissy-en-brie moi ce
que je voudrais pas c'est que dans une
république une et indivisible comme la
république française on est de la
sécurité publique à deux vitesses tout
le monde quelle que soit la ville où il
habite quels que soient les moyens de
cette ville doivent avoir droit à la
sécurité et à la sûreté en voyant les
policiers par le palais je suis député
de la taxe à mener je constate
qu'aujourd'hui un officier de police
judiciaire en seine-saint-denis la 300
dossiers par officier national et quand
un officier de police judiciaire à paris
en a 80 et donc au nom de quoi les
renforcer oui mes moyens de la police
nationale oui mais c'est faux ferait
même tourné vers la vie des frères est
empli de disparités david dufresne joue
rapidement parce que le débat s'achève
et des difficiles à distance il faut
leur bien le reconnaître mais nous vous
écoutons il y à cette question de la
police municipale au-delà des questions
des libertés gars d'autres dispositifs
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire aux
députés qui nous écoutent pas jouer
surtout spectateurs je voudrais
m'adresser c'est à dire que il faut bien
comprendre que cette loi de sécurité
globale qui portait par monsieur
fauvergue là à l'écran en fait c'est une
pochette surprise c'est à dire que le
le coeur c'était la police municipale et
ont été ajoutés ces dernières semaines
l'utilisation massive des drones ont été
ajoutés le fameux article 24 dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est à dire de
sorte que nous avons un millefeuille
législatif qui est votée en urgence
alors qu'il n'y a aucun caractère
d'urgence
en réalité et c'est ce qui montre à mon
avis la préparation de la commission on
a bien vu les débats jeudi vendredi
dernier on verra à l'hémicycle mardi on
voit comment ça monte dans la presse de
manière assez rapide
pourquoi parce que il ya un millefeuille
c'est quelque chose qui n'est absolument
pas clair cette loi de sécurité globale
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on veut faire
plaisir à certains syndicats de police
on veut leur donner leur donner ce petit
cadeau qui coûtent pas cher alors qu'en
fait on parle de télésurveillance de
surveillance par drones de libertés
publiques de liberté de la presse et de
renforcement d'une police municipale qui
viendrait se substituer ces des soins à
la police nationale s'est dit merci je
vais donner quasiment le mot de la fin
mais je vous donnerai avoue jean-michel
fauvergue aux policiers qu'ils nous
écoutent françois bersani
on vous donnerait dégage finalement ce
texte serait plus politique que
nécessaire sur sur le fond il attendra
les libertés il ya aussi on n'en a pas
parlé
l'élargissement de la surveillance par
drones dont parlait david dufresne
on vous donne des gages avec ce texte
c'est tout non il ya des revendications
légitimes des policiers nationaux
que ce soit dans les moyens qui leur
sont donnés de faire respecter la
sécurité publique en france et de ne pas
être perturbé dans l'exercice de leur
mission de protection de la population
par des actes hostiles à leur égard et
surtout la chasse la chasse aux
policiers en toute impunité sur les
réseaux sociaux je crois que ce projet
était dense dans ce sens là qu'il a été
fondé maintenant on sait que le conseil
constitutionnel est très sourcilleux sur
tous les textes qui sont à la limite de
à des droits de l'homme est en tout cas
des libertés individuelles
donc si ce texte est jugée
inconstitutionnelle il sera il sera
déféré devant le conseil constitutionnel
est certainement des faits dont il n'y a
pas d'inquiétude à avoir
et puis la liberté de la presse et tous
les jours on peut construire on peut
constater qu'elle existe la liberté de
la presse puisque sur toutes les
manifestations gilet jaune loi elle
conneries ou à la sphère benalla dont
vous avez parlé on a bien eu la liberté
de la presse et qui a pu communiquer ces
images on n'y a pas d'inquiétude encore
une fois le policier
enfin le plus tôt là le citoyen français
qui chaque jour se déplace dans la
sphère publique et qui ne pose pas de
délit ou de crime
il n'a pas à avoir peur d'une caméra de
vidéosurveillance d'un drone ou de la
police musique merci merci beaucoup
france à marseille on va s'arrêter là
les arguments ont pu être échangé vous
allez rester avec moi parce qu'on va
parler un petit peu de votre livre à
présent jean michel fauvergue merci
stéphane peu je le dis dès du raid à
l'assemblée un parcours atypique et une
expérience dans la lutte antiterroriste
ont en partie au titre
[Musique]
jean michel faubert
on va regarder votre portrait dans un
instant mais pour répondre est terminée
véritablement sur les arguments de david
dufresne
il nous dit entre les lignes que c'est
emmanuel macron lui même qui a tenu la
plume notamment sur ces questions qui
touchent aux libertés au diffusion
d'image ce texte c'est lui qui l'a écrit
en partie je vous réponds clairement sur
un certain nombre de choses et je vais
faire le lien avec ceux avec ce livre
ce qui m'importe est tout le temps en
main dans ma vie de policier pendant 40
ans et qui maintenant m'importe dans ma
vie de député c'est la sécurité de nos
concitoyens c'est le conseil de la
sécurité des français ce texte est issu
d'un rapport qui a duré avec ali que
nous avons fait avec alice taureau qui a
duré six mois sur lequel vous avez fait
incertain nous avons fait un certain
nombre de propositions donc c'est pas un
message sur lesquels ce texte elle est
logique claire c'est une meilleure
sécurité au service des citoyens
français avec la police d'état et la
gendarmerie la police municipale les
secteurs privés de sécurité qu'on l'a
craint de reconstruire plus la
protection de ceux qui nous protège et
c'est d'y aller un super flic à
l'assemblée c'est suffisamment rare jean
michel faubert ça méritait un petit
portrait signé clément mérite qu'on
regarde ensemble
un ancien flic qui entre en politique
2010 est en pleine campagne
présidentielle jean michel fauvergue
fait partie de la poignée de candidats
aux législatives qu'emmanuel macron
présente en direct à la télévision alors
on reconnaît jean michel faubert voilà
il ya quelques semaines il était patron
du raid
si les députés demain il aura rien à
envier à eric ciotti pour vous parler
des hérissons sécurité et vous rien du
tout pour emmanuel macron c'est un
ralliement de poids car le personnage
impose le respect 39 ans de carrière
dans la police est un fait d'armes
unanimement salué le 9 janvier 2015
c'est lui qui dirige l'assaut du raid et
de la br i contrat mehdi coulibaly
retranchés dans l'hyper cacher le
terroriste a déjà abattu quatre
personnes
les 26 otages sont libérés sains et
saufs c'est la plus grande fierté de
l'ancien patron du ray après vincennes
il ya une énorme fierté comme qu'on a
fêté ensemble avec les normes fierté de
sauver des gens de sauver des vies c'est
c'est inimaginable de sauver des vies
mais un autre souvenir hante jean-michel
fauvergue le bataclan bataclan
ces images elles continuent à volonté
passé par le gipn les stups la police
aux frontières
jean-michel fauvergue trouve au raid
l'aboutissement d'une carrière dédiée à
l'action et au terrain le secteur a été
bouclé et le site passé au peigne fin
ce vaste coup de filet a permis
l'interpellation de quatre malfaiteurs
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il est
effectivement dangereux puisqu'ils on a
essuyé un coup de feu seule ombre dans
cette carrière exemplaire le récit qu'il
fera de l'assaut de l'appartement de
saint denis
on s'était retranché about et deux
complices
après le bataclan il était dans un dans
un appartement
avec des kalachnikov avec des grenades
avec défilé sans doute jill et des
gilets explosifs et il fallait sur le
raid
voilà quoi sur place les enquêteurs ne
retrouveront pas de kalachnikov
mais un simple pistolet écarté du raid
en mars 2017
jean-michel fauvergue reste fidèle à sa
devise servir sans faillir au service
d'un homme
emmanuel macron voilà et cette
expérience vous la raconter dans ce
livre gign raid coécrit avec thierry
orosco l'ancien patron du gign deux
patrons face aux nouvelles menaces et
ces nouvelles menaces qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui jean-michel fauvergue
aujourd'hui elles ne sont plus multi
sites comme c'était le cas avec le
bataclan aujourd'hui ce sont des
individus qui passent sous les radars et
qui souvent ne sont pas fichés est-ce
qu'on est suffisamment armé est-ce qu'on
est suffisamment formé nos hommes nos
unités d'élite mais aussi on en parlait
nos policiers sur le terrain souvent
municipaux pour faire face à ces
nouvelles menaces
vous avez raison de dire que la menace a
changé la menace a changé dans la
manière de faire les choses on est passé
par exemple sur le bataclan à une
des attentats de deux réseaux organisés
de l'extérieur et de l'intérieur à un
terrorisme endogène il faut savoir que
la france comme d'autres pays européens
malheureusement produit sur son sol des
enfants à elle qui disent qu'ils vont se
retourner contre elle et qui vont être
dans qui vont devenir terroriste
effectivement vous me demandez si on est
suffisamment armé je vous dirais que on
n'est jamais il suffisamment armé pour
faire face à l'ensemble de ces menaces
mais en progrès si on progresse tout le
temps mais on ne sera jamais à l'abri
jamais à l'abri d'une d'une action qui
va se décider au dernier moment d'une
action qui peut révoquer zéro n'exist
ait pas tu peux faire des milliers des
dizaines de morts comme comme comme on a
vu à annie les députés est-ce qu'on est
suffisamment armée juridiquement vous
l'entendez ce débat qui monte de
l'extrême droite d'une partie de la
droite il faut adapter l'état de droit
il ya elle brawn pire et présidente de
la commission des lois dit aujourd'hui
qu'elle
il faut que le conseil conjugue du sio
neil s'adapte vous êtes d'accord
l'expriment conseil constitutionnel a
pris une grande une très grande
responsabilité en en strass en la loi
sur les sortants de prison une très
grande responsabilité suivi des dialyses
des détenus socialiste qui est tout à
fait il faut il faut que tous les to les
les organes qui composent cet état
s'adaptent à cette menace là et que
certains ne reste pas au bord du chemin
en faisant leur jurisprudence à partir
de situations qui sont des situations
qui sont maintenant date et il faut
arriver à travailler parce qu'on doit
tous tout ce temps que l'on est on doit
la protection aux français merci
beaucoup sont présents michel fauvergue
d'être passé sur le plateau de lcp gign
reds et aux éditions mareuil à cliquer
et connectés dans toutes les bonnes
librairies que s'est il passé ces
dernières 24 heures au palais bourbon on
sait à l'heure de retrouver la chronique
de thomas des prêts thomas qui va nous
parler d'un débat qui commence à monter
dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale faut-il se mettre
définitivement au vote par
correspondance pourquoi on ne longtin ne
l'ont ne l'at on pas déjà fait
explications avec thomas des prêts oui
exactement myriam un vote par
correspondance comme aux états unis
serait il souhaitable
france c'était la question du jour à
l'assemblée je vous raconte tout ça
alors on l'a vu de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique les américains se sont en
sur mobilisés pour ces élections
présidentielles notamment en votant par
correspondance
du coup ça a donné une idée un député du
modem il veut réintroduire en france ce
vote par correspondance
mais pour quoi faire on lui a posé la
question bonjour jean noël barrot
cette proposition c'est vous qui la
portait concrètement c'est quoi ce vote
par correspondance
écoutez c'est une proposition qui est
portée de longue date par le modem une
proposition de loi a été déposé par les
députés du groupe modem dès le mois de
juin
l idéal est simple c'est avec
l'abstention n'est pas une fatalité
qu'une grande démocratie comme la france
peut traverser les crises sans avoir à
mettre à l'arrêt la démocratie et que
nos concitoyens ne doivent pas avoir à
choisir entre l'expression de leurs
droits civiques et leur santé c'est
l'exemple américain qui vous a donné
l'idée de remettre cette proposition sur
le tapis parce qu'il s'est passé aux
états unis est un des exemples mais vous
savez en pleine crise sanitaire au
printemps en allemagne et en bavière en
particulier le second tour des élections
municipales s'est tenue à 100% par
correspondance sans aucun problème alors
cette proposition allait loin de faire
l'unanimité du côté des députés en fait
le vote par correspondance il a déjà
existé en france mais on l'a stoppé en
1975 pour diverses raisons
alors cette fois-ci faut-il leur maître
on a demandé aux députés le vote par
correspondance vous qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mais je pense qu'il faut au
moins se poser la question moi je suis
député d'amérique du nord
on a 150 millions d'américains qui
viennent de voter on n'a jamais autant
américains ont voté et c'est en partie
grâce au vote par correspondance comme
l'a dit le président larcher je pense
que c'est une seule une piste qui peut
être étudiée examiné mais sur lequel il
ne peut y avoir aucun doute en matière
de procédure et aujourd'hui encore des
doutes et des incertitudes
c'est clair que le vote par
correspondance il ya un moyen de
pression plus important que le vote
individuel aujourd'hui on l'a arrêté en
france il est maintenant bien longtemps
parce que c'était un objet de fraudes
massives le réintroduire pour avoir de
la fraude massive je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la meilleure façon d'augmenter la
participation des citoyens entièrement
gelé gens votent quand y'a pas d'enlever
votre pas quand ils ont l'impression que
les jeux sont faits il va être pas quand
ils ont l'impression que leur parole
n'est pas entendue ne vote pas
lorsqu'ils ont l'impression que tout se
décide sans eux ne votent pas et donc
répond d'abord à ces questions
et puis ensuite on peut trouver des
aménagements pour faciliter des votes et
qu'en pense le gouvernement alors gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est lui qui gère les élections a donné
son avis tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
et il n'est pas vraiment vraiment pour
sommes pas capables aujourd'hui d'être
sûr que ce scrutin comme le scrutin
électronique soit entièrement
incontestable vu que effectivement avec
des cas de fraudes peuvent être relevés
et nous avons fait le choix de l'isoloir
de l'urne et des préaux d'école pour
caricaturer
je souhaite pour ma part qu'on puisse
continuer à voter librement dans un
isoloir voit la manière mais toujours à
propos d'élections noter que c'est
vendredi que l'ancien président du
conseil constitutionnel jean louis debré
remettra au premier ministre son rapport
sur la tenue ou non des élections
départementales et régionales
c'est à ce moment là que l'on devrait
savoir si ces élections sont reportées
ou pas merci thomas allez on en vient à
notre décryptage ce soir on va se
pencher sur les conséquences économiques
dures confinement cette deuxième vague
alors que vous le savez les commerçants
sont plus qu'inquiets pour leur avenir
la france at elle les moyens d'absorber
ce nouveau choc avant de vous présenter
nos invités les clés pour comprendre
on va voir ça tout de suite avec elsa
monde un gala j'ai décidé qu'il fallait
retrouver à partir de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus
leur confinement quel impact sur
l'économie
ce confinement nouvelle version a
évidemment moins de conséquences selon
la banque de france
il coûtera à l'économie française 12% de
son pib par rapport à un mois normal
par comparaison en avril dernier
l'économie s'était contractée de 31%
il faut dire qu'alors elle avait été mis
sous cloche
cette fois ci le travail continue sur
l'année alors que le gouvernement
prévoyait une récession à moins 10% du
pib
il l'a réévaluée à -11%
quels sont les secteurs les plus touchés
alors que l'industrie et le bâtiment
était quasiment à l'arrêt au printemps
ces secteurs vivre un automne quasi
stable en revanche la restauration les
commerces dits non essentiel et des
loisirs sont touchés de plein fouet les
restaurants bars et cafés ce sont deux
cent mille entreprises en france qui
emploient 800 mille personnes leur
principal syndicat dit craindre jusqu'à
30000 fermeture soit 200000 emplois
quelles aides de l'état fonds de
solidarité prêts garantis décalage des
charges au printemps comme à l'automne
l'état se dit prête à mettre la main à
la poche tout sera mis en oeuvre pour
protéger nos salariés et pour protéger
nos entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte comme au printemps
le quoi qu'il en coûte cette réponse
économique
parmi les plus protectrices du monde se
poursuivra le nouveau collectif
budgétaire à bond de 20 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires les aides aux
entreprises touchées plus de 3 milliards
d'euros par exemple pour financer le
chômage partiel
au plus fort de la crise près de 9
millions de salariés étaient concernés
un peu plus d'un million en septembre
l'état dit s'attendre à une remontée en
flèche du dispositif avec le nouveau
confinement
toutes ces mesures essaye de retarder
d'éventuelles faillites d'entreprises
mais permettent elles de les éviter la
crise financière de 2009 avait causé
plus de 60000 défaillances d'entreprises
mais cette crise et d'un genre nouveau
avec autant de nouvelles vagues d'euros
confirmant possible et autant de
soubresauts pour l'économie française
bonsoir bruno bonnell merci d'être avec
nous est député en marge du rhône et
entrepreneurs mathieu plane est
également avec nous ravie de vous
retrouver vous êtes économiste lfc eux
et par skype anne-sophie al cif bonsoir
vous êtes chef et au bip c'est un
cabinet de conseil en stratégie bureau
d'information de prévisions économiques
vous êtes spécialiste des questions
macro économique et dette souveraine 20
milliards de plus d'un milliard de
dépenses en plus 15 + 5 pour voir venir
voilà donc le montant de la facture du
nouveau collectif budgétaire
le couple au projet de loi de finances
rectificatif sur lequel vous vous
planchez c'est le quatrième franchement
qu'est ce que vous dites
qu'est ce que vous dites à tous ces
petits patrons pme de commerçants quand
on entend le gouvernement dira ça va
tenir
on va limiter les dégâts c'est très
difficile à croire
il ya deux sujets différents
le sujet seuil est ce qu'il y à un état
au monde qui essayent de supporter
autant sont issus de commerçants et de
petites entreprises non ça veut dire
qu'il ya un effort réel qui est fait par
la nation est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour recouvrir une activité normale
mensuel pour chacun d'entre eux pour la
plupart d'entre eux n'ont faut être bien
clair aura de la casse il y aura de la
casse il y aura de la casse mais mais il
ya aussi une transformation qui est en
route la coved s'éteint c'est aussi une
manière dans là je parle en tant
qu'entrepreneur de se remettre en
question de réévaluer un petit peu ces
stratégies
j'étais dans une boutique ouverte il ya
pas longtemps ou en discuter il y avait
un la boutique d'à côté c'est une
boutique de jouets donc fermé t'es en
train de parler et j'ai dit mais où
est-ce que vous avez mis en place le
click n connect il dit c'est cher non
parce que par exemple il ya une chose
que ne se connaissent pas les articles
led light 200 euros non il ya l'aide de
500 euros et il ya des prêts spécifiques
des pays qui sont vingt jours mais
d'investissements pour mettre en place
le click and collect mais il faut
arrêter qui que ces commerçants pensent
que cette crise est une parenthèse vers
un retour à la normale il faut se dire
c'est une transformation qui permettrait
par exemple pour ses boutiques de
rajouter demain à leurs activités
traditionnelles une petite activités
digitales on entend bercy qui tente de
rassurer en disant que la baisse ou
l'arrêt de l'activité sera modéré au
début on nous a dit il va y avoir une
reprise en v
c'est raté 1 on a tous pas toucher le
fond pour rebondir ensuite on nous a dit
ce sera un u les macroéconomistes nous
disent on va toucher le fond ça va durer
et puis ça va remonter
on a l'impression de vivre un w en
zigzag
on touche le fond tente de remonter on
va retoucher le fond on peut se remettre
de ce genre de cycle
de crise il va falloir se remettra jeudi
on va éviter tout le monde souhaite
l'effondrement de l'économie parce que
derrière c'est des conséquences sociales
qui serait terrible donc bien sûr que le
gouvernement a un rôle clé à jouer on le
voit il ya quand même des dispositifs
qui ont été et pour le compound quand
même les saluer ce sont les dispositifs
de fonds de solidarité notamment pour
les pme on et on va jusqu'à 10000 euros
pour ces petites boîtes de compensation
sur le chiffre d'affaires avec une
négociation possible sur les loyers donc
là c'est quand même une avancée réelle
par rapport à ce qu'il y avait au
printemps elle élargit le fonds de
solidarité
oui ce qui manquait à mon avis au départ
et c'est pour ça que c'est deuxième lame
est dur parce que c'est sur une économie
qui est très fragile des secteurs qui
sont très fragilisées qui sont beaucoup
endettées que des pg e par l'état les
prêts garantis par l'état des reports de
dette fiscale qui va falloir un moment
rembourser ça va être là aussi que ça va
être crucial mais ce que peut-être
également et peut-être assez mal intégré
je trouve au départ c'est justement tous
les coûts fixes qui avait au delà de la
masse salariale c'est-à-dire les
équipements que vous devez rembourser le
matériel de transport et c'est là le
gouvernement demande notamment aux
bailleurs d'ornon c'est tout simplement
alors noyé de novembre ça je crois que
ça marchera pas sera pas forcément très
efficace mais par contre sur le fond de
solidarité les 10000 euros ça quand même
ça élargit quand même les chutes
l'échelle des délais des personnes
concernées et nourrit le chiffre
d'affaires il faut voir c'est en tête
c'est que là on est sur plus de 10
milliards 11 milliards je crois alors
qu'au printemps la crise était plus
sévère il y avait eu que 8 milliards
débloqués sur le fond de solidarité
donc là c'est plus ciblée sur les
commerces et les petits commerces et
l'enveloppé plus large donc là c'est
plutôt quelque chose à saluer mais
malheureusement ça arrive quand même
dans une deuxième vague qui fait très
mal pour beaucoup de d'entreprises qui
ont déjà beaucoup de difficultés
actuellement qu'il va y avoir forcément
des des faillites
anne-sophie al cif on le dit au fond la
france a un modèle social des filets de
sécurité beaucoup de mesures de soutien
on entend les reports de de
remboursement de prêts
l'élargissement du fonds de solidarité
et puis il ya des prévisions de
croissance 8 % 8 % ça vous semble
imaginables ou de toute façon on ne peut
rien prévoir
alors je pense qu'on peut prévoir et que
ça peut être imaginable en fonction de
comment sera le rebond c'est ça la
grande question par rapport en effet au
risque d'effondrement je pense qu'il ya
deux éléments qui sont quand même très
différent dans le confinement convient
actuellement c'est déjà tout ce qui est
le secteur industriel par rapport au
premier confinement là vous avez comme
l'idée c'est quand même de sauvegarder
l'économie
les usines l'industrie qui continuent de
fonctionner vous avez la chine je le
rappelle qu'à 2% de croissance cette
année à la chine n'est pas en récession
ils ne subissent pas une seconde vague
aussi importante que la nôtre
et donc il n'y aura pas de rupture dans
les chaînes de valeur et pour
l'industrie européenne c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'il n'y aura pas
de problème d'approvisionnement et on
voit également au niveau du commerce
international une reprise et le secteur
manufacturier créer plus de valeur
ajoutée
donc ça c'est un élément important pour
justement prévoir la croissance et la
reprise par contre l'autre effet qui est
malheureusement plus difficile comme l'a
dit notamment mathieu c'est vraiment le
problème des pme des petites entreprises
dans les services qu'ils ont déjà été
très affecté par le premier confinement
qui sont beaucoup plus endetté qui vont
du mal à faire face malgré les nouvelles
mesures est à mon sens même si dans les
activités on voit beaucoup
d'hétérogénéité et des baisses qui sont
moins forte qu'au premier confirme en
moins 15 à moins de 30
à mon sens le problème c'est vraiment la
confiance parce que lors du premier
confinement il y avait un peu l'idée de
dire ça y est on a un confinement
important c'est fini et on a vu vraiment
un rebond de la consommation à la fin du
premier confinement c'est très très très
très forte hausse notamment dans le
commerce de détail
or là on est dans une mouvance où on se
dit il y à un mois de confinement turcs
ont filmé puis déconfinement pur
confinement donc du coup on n'est pas du
tout je pense pour le consommateur et
c'est vraiment le risque dans une haie
de diers et 20 maximum en va d épargne
et sachant qu'il ya eu
me mouiller singulière pardon de d'euros
ont été collectés lors du premier
conflit alors la question de la
confiance sur toute la relance se base
là dessus sur la conscience la confiance
du consommateur voilà
plan de relance est presque d'ores et
déjà un peu obsolète
la confiance est aussi les politiques
les élus que vous êtes comment vous
faites pour redonner confiance aux
français comment vous faites pour leur
dire au fond continuer à consommer alors
qu'on ne sait même pas si on ne sera
épargné d'une troisième vague 1 il faut
pas leur mentir et leur dire
qu'effectivement l'hypothèse de ne pas
résoudre par ce deuxième confinement
totalement le virus est une hypothèse
réelle et arrêter de dire comme je
l'entends à longueur de commentaires
on sera ensemble pour noël on sera pas
ensemble pour noël on n'en sait rien il
faut juste dire aux gens qu'on est dans
cette zone d'incertitudes qui fait qu'à
l'heure où nous parlons
on ne saura que dans quelques semaines
probablement la fin du mois de novembre
si on a une chance ou pas il fallait
bien que l'incertitude favori d'un gagne
doublé vital non mais attendez je ne
suis pas le click and collect la gauche
sur le plan macroéconomique on voit une
réaction tout à fait logique et les gens
épargnent parce qu'ils savent pas de
quoi demain sera fait donc il se prépare
à toute éventualité
mais ça le politique n'y peut pas grand
chose c'est une réaction de masse une
réaction de foule qui est connu depuis
que le monde est monde quand les gens
sont inquiets ils achètent de l'or et de
la pierre là ils font de l'épargné ils
ont saturé à pratiquement tous les plans
d'épargné mobilier mais on doit un pas
leur mentir
2 mettre en place des systèmes qui
puisse dans la mesure de ce qui est
supportable sur le plan budgétaire
soutenir des entreprises en difficulté
et il n'y a que cette équation là qu'on
peut résoudre aujourd'hui on est
supportable au niveau budgétaire c'est
toujours ok c'est toujours bon on
continue à s'endetter n'y a pas de soi
les l'arbitrage qui va être fait dans
beaucoup de pays y compris si on a une
troisième vague il faudra continuer à
soutenir
c'est à dire que c'est c'est la question
ça sera après c'est à dire comme on
règle la facture qu'est-ce qui peut être
mutualisés qu'est ce qui peut être de la
dette bce qui peut être sur du très long
terme ça sert avec des questions très
importantes sur le règlement de la
facture mais là pour le moment c'est on
est là pour sauver les meubles
c'est à dire faire en sorte que
l'économie ça fait ce pas totalement qui
est pas des faillites en cascade qu'on
n'est pas un tissu productif qui se
délite complètement con n'est pas un
chômage qui explose donc c'est pour ça
la relance pour vous
oui alors on l'avait signalé quand même
c'était fait la cire que dans le plan de
relance il manquait sérieusement l'idée
de la gestion du court terme enfin ça
n'est jamais vous l'avez dit l'horizon
temporel il n'est pas à deux ou trois
ans il a une semaine deux semaines on
sait pas et donc c'est par exemple
comment on fait pour renforcer les fonds
propres
typiquement effectivement face au vice
et qu'est ce qu'on fait sur les pg e
donc là c'est vraiment des mécaniques de
très court terme un qu'il faut être
capable de mettre au bloc et vous
trouvez quelque chose de nouveau la
question mon avis qui va être très très
sensible c'est la durée du confinement
ça on vous l'avait dit on va voir en
fonction d'évolutions d'épidémie mais
mon avis l'enjeu les plus durs celle sur
le déconfinement c'est-à-dire pour
éviter qu'on se retrouve dans des
politiques de stop and go et sait
comment trouver le bon équilibre
la ligne de crête qui permet d'avoir à
peu près une activité continue normale
sans avoir à risque de recrutement ce
que les confinements en termes de coûts
économiques sont colossaux donc il faut
les éviter
et c'est vrai que pour le moment on n'a
pas tellement la solution j'ai
l'impression éviter le stop and go and
social cif
peut-être qu'on peut dire un mot de ces
secteurs qui entre guillemets profite du
duc au vide il ya quand même encore des
secteurs porteurs pendant cette crise
alors oui il ya une très grande les
secteurs son projet d'une manière très
très très différenciée alors bien
évidemment hébergement restauration à
les plus touchées 3% notre pipe donc là
vraiment des baisses en fonction de si
ces commerces peuvent faire de la
restauration emporté des bears qui
seront entre 30 40 % vous avez bien sûr
tout ce qui la construction qui sera un
peu un pack très patient aura un impact
de l'investissement même s'il a les
chantiers ne sont pas à la règle il
avait subi une forte baisse de
l'activité aviation avec le premier
confinement on a tout ce qui est service
aux entreprises là qui sont quand même
des secteurs qui résistent beaucoup
mieux 1
là vous avez des baisses qui sont
estimés à 3 4% et kiko aussi beaucoup de
valeur ajoutée
donc il ya vraiment des secteurs qui
sont très très très impactées à plus de
30% hébergement restauration commerce
et puis tout ce qui est plus dans le
tertiaire les services voilà surtout aux
entreprises qui l'a s'en sortent mieux
et qui sont aussi sûrement un vecteur de
résidence pour la reprise et qui aussi
permettront peut-être d'être un bon bouc
et pour éviter les fameuses hausses
d'emploi que l'on attend s'il ya de
beaucoup de faillites d'entreprises au
dernier trimestre et au premier
trimestre et 2021 merci beaucoup
le chômage évidemment augmente chômage
partiel il n'y a pas de créations
d'emplois il ya plus de destructions
vous avez exactement 10 secondes pour
nous donner une raison d'espérer pour y
conclure la transformation on a connu
ces périodes là sont des périodes qui
ont ressemblé pareil on m'a dit sorti de
guerre et on a vu que toute l'économie
s'est transformée parce que les
habitudes de consommation et 10 ont
changé merci à vous merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur lcp je vous
retrouve demain
très belle soirée impôts
[Musique]